say hello to sema leo everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you it's my first one so
i knew i had to uh make it count you
know i
am very excited about your movie i have
to lead with that it's also very lovely
to meet you but that just energized me
so much
i'm very excited i can't wait for it and
it all started this is what i love
everything started from you tweeting
this tweet in 2014.
hey marvel great job with captain
america and thor now how about an
asian-american hero
so did you have any expectations after
that tweet of maybe them possibly
reaching out um yeah yeah for sure you
know i tweeted uh in you know 2014 and i
was like uh like a struggling actor i
was handing out dog food samples on the
side of the road in toronto and i was
like yeah i'm gonna tweet marvel and
it's gonna be great they're gonna you
know read the tweet get back to me offer
me a role and so basically everything's
worked out as planned and uh that's
amazing years later absolutely no idea
it was gonna happen it was just kind of
a facetious thing that i tweeted
and um you know it's what's happening in
these next few years has just been
pretty incredible and pretty insane so
i'm still pinching myself every day to
be honest um but after getting the part
um you replied to your own tweet lol
which was awesome
you're like hey you know what i am
nostradamus um
almost to the day actually it was july
17th and i was like i was cast on july
21st oh my god crazy that works out oh
my god so what other jobs did you have
when you were starting out i had a
billion so yeah yeah okay let's see so
we covered handing out dog food samples
on the side of the street and then i was
so random
i also just kind of picked up like you
know weird you know acting slash
modeling gigs whenever i could and like
when i say modeling i'm not i'm i wasn't
like a runway prada model
i was like uh it was like a stock you
know stock photos
wait like when you buy the picture frame
like when you yeah when you buy the
picture frame exactly or like when
you're going i don't think those
families are so beautiful
i'm like sometimes yeah thank you yeah
i'm like well done if they cast you for
that um yeah the one i did like a couple
of shoots and they ended up like man i
like i literally keep seeing it pop up
and like more so now because people are
recognizing them and uh putting them
online but i feel like i've been like
i've been like all around the world
i've traveled i've been on like the
front of stores i've hung outside gyms
and been on the cover of textbooks and
it's uh it's really really wild yeah
well and it all led you to chongqing
which i'm very excited about so tell us
about your your motivation and some of
these photos because there are some
photos that are pretty awesome here's
the first
so what's what's happening here oh man
is the merger are you discussing the
merger there's the merger there's a
merger kelly thank you thank you um
there's a lot going on in this guys
a lot of really really intense character
work yeah you know i i see my two
colleagues over here they're studying an
annual report right and i
over there leaning over the head of the
table and and leading this meeting all
right yes a leader you look like a
leader thank you yeah thank you that was
what the motivation was you nailed it
how about this one this is our next one
so what's happening okay okay so here's
jovial look how happy everyone's really
happy all right i think i've just i
think i've just saved the company a lot
of money here right so i've discovered
you know in monopoly when you pick up a
chance card and they're like bank error
in your favor well i've just discovered
one of those and um you know my my boss
uh you know one of her associates is uh
yeah is uh is looking over my shoulder
and there and they're like wow wow
you've saved the company i like it i
like it um and you you saw something you
liked in this last one
you liked it yep you're very happy about
it i think i've been promoted since the
last photo i feel like you're gonna sell
me the best house in the entire land
[Music]